for all of the history up until this
point our communication structures have
for the most part especially mass media
systems have been very top-down and
they've been controlled by a few people
that had distribution control if you
look back the church was really the
first broadcast network the church built
out a very defined architecture of
communication that was coming from a
centralized place where very few people
could have the Word of God come down to
them and they had the ability to
transcribe this is at a point when
literacy was very rare and so you had
only a few people that were literate
that could transcribe this this holy
word and then they would distribute it
out to a local market where you had a
big impressive building that had lots of
iconography and lots of beautiful images
inside of it and the tallest building
usually in the town and they would ring
the steeple at you know 8 a.m. and we
would all congregate for mass and we
would listen to one message from one
incontrovertible truth from one source
and that's not too dissimilar from
television architecture right you have a
group of people in suits in New York or
in Los Angeles and they're deciding
what's going to be on television and
then they distribute it to those towers
and at seven pm prime time we aggregate
around the television that's been
brought into our home and we watch this
one incontrovertible truth in this
signal from a top-down approach and when
the internet started enabling people
first with this underlying network
architecture of tcp/ip that allowed us
to transcend time and distance that
allowed any node on the network to
contribute to the system and then we
started seeing things like video sharing
and photo sharing that allowed us all to
become publishers and then we have this
kind of now this layer of social that
has is redefining everything where every
single person is now contributing node
on the network and every person that is
part of
that uses emotions and memes and content
to distribute things in a horizontal
fashion and so what that's doing is is
that is destroying the ability to
discern what is authentic what is not
what's real what's fake what commercial
what's non-commercial what sponsored
what's non-sponsored what's a good idea
versus a bad idea and so when we exist
in this free form society where every
note on the network can contribute
something to the network and it has no
checks and balances if you will there is
no top-down authority that's editing it
or or deciding what's what's real or not
then suddenly it becomes every note on
the network's responsibility real having
to learn a pattern of behavior that
we're all responsible for the
propagation of this content because the
one interesting rule is it's very
difficult to make a mass media statement
in a cellular colonic structure nodal
network because you have to get a bunch
of people to agree to share it and agree
to propagate no big media company can
behind their way into the system anymore
right but at the same time every if
everyone's on a balanced playing field
then people that are hackers or people
that scam the system or people that you
know kind of arbitrage the new ad
features that emerge or decide to take
this path have an advantage over some of
the try too intrusive institutions you
know especially in things like the
context of fake news that's been
happening a lot you know the idea that a
bunch of Macedonian teenagers that are
arbitrage ad dollars on facebook system
can put hundreds of stories into a
network that people believe these fake
news stories when a new york times or a
Wall Street Journal refuses to pay for
play in a system like Facebook and so
you have this great imbalance because we
haven't learned yet how to we haven't
taught ourselves yet how to discern
what's real and what's fake and how to
look at sources and how to you know how
to how to see them for what they are and
that's also because of a lack
transparency we're living in the systems
now that are controlling our ability to
disseminate information and we have no
transparency whatsoever when it comes to
algorithms why does content behave this
way why one day when I post something to
500 people does it reach and the next
day only five people reaches and so
until we have visibility into that
system and into these algorithms we're
going to be at a bit of a loss and a bit
of a kind of grabbing in the dark trying
to make sense of this new communication
architecture you know I quote Aldous
Huxley so big no paraphrase and
basically says you know the only part of
the universe you can possibly control is
yourself and now more than ever that
kind of social responsibility is is upon
each one of us right because we're now
we're in a whole onyx istam right and
you know a cellular colonic system that
we are all responsible for the
propagation of the right information
positive information negative
information fake information you know
we're all responsible for it because
we're all part of a metabolic factor
inside of the system you know the
sharing of these memes is propelled by
emotions so human emotions are the
metabolism of the system and you can tap
into human curiosity in human you know
the whole range of emotions from you
know anger to laughter to you know
desire and so we're seeing that played
out in real time right now
[Music]